from the calmness of the european
union's court of justice in luxembourg
comes what amounts to a bombshell in
this crisis involving poland and the eu
the text is brief ecj vice president
orders poland to pay a fine of 1 million
euros a day because it's failed to
suspend a disciplinary chamber of its
supreme court that order was made in
july
in a country where the vast majority of
people support membership of the
european union its government has been
defying legal reforms ordered by the eu
poland stands accused by brussels of
political interference with a new
disciplinary system for judges
polish judges have declared that some eu
laws clash with their constitution even
before the latest action the governing
party of poland accused the eu of
blackmail the 1.2 million dollar fine
from brussels coincided with a harsh
warning from belgium's prime minister
aimed at polish leaders we are playing
with fire
when waging war with our european
colleagues for internal political
reasons this is about an overwhelming
majority of member states from the
baltics to portugal
who agree our union is a union of values
not a cash machine
you cannot pocket all the money but
refuse the
values that attack contrasted with the
diplomatic approach the french president
emmanuel macron had been taking with the
polish leader andrei duda however macron
had said well ahead of this meeting that
poland needed to make concrete proposals
the question now is whether poland will
be compliant or defiant
what's next it's hard to say you could
expect now the polish government to say
well sorry we're not able to pay this
fine because
our own polish constitutional court has
said
that this
would not
be in line with the polish constitution
can the polish government afford to keep
going against the majority view of
polish people who value eu membership
that is unclear
andrew simmons al jazeera